to an upland village in the state of
Virginia the first Tuesday in every
month there comes a truckload of books
the traveling library has many friends
among these remote farming people the
free book service provides them with a
much needed link to the world beyond
their Hills the librarian has her
friends too they want to know whether
the story has a sad ending or they need
her help with a strange word now and
then copyright that's not very strange
Tim you'll find it in most any book you
open it means that for 28 years no one
but the book's author or publisher can
copy anything from it it means well
let's see have you ever heard of the
Library of Congress Tim this book tells
all about it it's the most important
library in the country and one of the
things it does nowadays is keep records
and proofs of all the copyrights that
are issued by the United States two
copies of almost every book that is
published are sent to the library at
Washington
at Washington directly opposite the
Capitol in which Congress meets stands
the grandiose building that is America's
citadel of the written word an Arsenal
in the battle against ignorance a
monument to the ideals of free
expression and free thought
the Library of Congress was first
established for the exclusive use of the
men who made America's laws but it has
since become the nation's reading room
open to every man surrounding the main
reading room with the stacks of general
reference books to which the reader can
come directly for the volumes he wants
brought in a library containing nearly 6
million books and pamphlets only a small
proportion can be kept at arm's length
the rest are stored in great stack rooms
where modern air conditioning has
eliminated the traditional must and dust
the housing of a great and diverse
collection of the materials of
scholarship presents many technical
problems the Library of Congress must
have files for its million-and-a-half
maps portfolios must be provided for
more than half a million prints and
cases are needed for the changing
display of selected groups of pictures
the Oriental division requires still
other special facilities
students come from all over the world
use this collection which is the largest
of its kind outside of Asia but
naturally the library is richest in a
source materials of American history a
history that is unique in having been
lived entirely within a period for which
there are written records a history that
is first told in many languages the
history of new Indies New France New
Holland New England a history of many
races including one that was nearly
extinguished in the writing of the
history for in the sixteenth century it
was a history of conquest of new lands
that were taken in the name of God but
plundered in the interests of men it was
to take another two hundred years to
bring forth a nation in this new world
conceived in strife and bloodshed but
born in the image of men's dreams the
library has the words by which the
dreams were made realities and pictures
of the dreamers were later called
statesmen Jefferson Franklin George
Washington these are the records of a
nation in labor its progenitors its
heroes and this the fruit of their
struggle the Articles of Confederation
was a blueprint for a republic the Bill
of Rights a set of rules by which the
people of the new nation might live in
peace and personal freedom a freedom
enjoyed today by millions whose
grandfathers were not even born when
this ink was wet
the union was once bitterly attacked and
had to be defended
men like Abraham Lincoln arose from the
people to lead the fight with inspired
courage and great wisdom they to our
office by their words and deeds they
wrote the history today preserved by the
library new methods of recording history
brought new media to the library's
collections these are prints of the
earliest newsreels in this old sequence
we see a parade in North Africa honoring
mr. Roosevelt but this Roosevelt as
Theodore Roosevelt and the occasion his
goodwill voyage in 1910 era preserved
the personalities of the men who have
guided the destiny of the nation and who
represented the United States in the
counsels that shaped the modern world
the mementos of leaders like Wilson will
be of interest to students of all
countries as long as history is written
and read
but the Library of Congress is more than
a mere treasure house recognizing the
fact that the use of the books is more
important in the possession of them it
is sought to provide every facility that
might ease the task of the trained
researcher or the ordinary reader key to
the entire system is the main catalog a
complete detailed listing of the
millions of books in these trays there
are over 16 million signposts to help
the reader find exactly what he's
looking for
in recent years have been many visitors
from distant countries where the right
to read has been denied to men because
of their politics their religion or
their race and in these files they've
been able to find the books that tyrants
have tried to burn and bomb and banished
from the face of the earth here the
heritage of our culture is available to
anyone who would reach for it
the library prints the reference cards
not only for its own catalogs but also
to send to other cities in other
countries where depository libraries are
located most countries take advantage of
this system and a large number send
their own cards back to Washington and
so the work of the library is carried
beyond its walls in a very process of
organizing knowledge it functions as a
creative force a strange treasure house
whose Guardians feel most successful
when they are sharing the treasure with
the whole world consulting the cards is
the first step in the process of getting
a particular book from the 414 miles of
shelves after the request form is filled
out the rest is almost automatic
in the rare book rooms properly
identified experts may touch and turn
the pages of volumes lettered by hand in
the Middle Ages or scrutinize rare
examples of the earliest printing the
Gutenberg Bible has become a symbol of
the technical developments that
eventually made reading possible for the
common man
five centuries later other developments
gave reading to those who so badly need
the opening vistas of books but who
cannot see the printed page I lost the
world the other day has anybody found
you will know it by the way Lord stars
around it spotted bones a rich man might
not notice it if my frugal I of more
esteem them Dudley today the library
provides talking books for the blind
readers and the library puts sound
recording to many other uses musicians
and sociologists can now study American
folk songs that have never been
transcribed and would otherwise be lost
if the library officials did not go to
the field to record unknown primitive
singers
well I heard Marty rumbling and then I
looked around was another 907 battle
roll on roll on roll on it never roll
I'm saying did bluehdi call Marlo but
the rustlers
from corners in the data
of mine zeros from
her blanket a battle
- bye
see Rose Brown
blanket with a gun in each hand
you Cowboys fight for your land
what the roots of music in America go
deep into the past and twist across
oceans and continents the music division
of the library can furnish the student
with all kinds of materials including
priceless old manuscripts this is the
original score of a Bach cantata and
this sir Mozart quintet even a
handwriting of a composer like Beethoven
is of interest to scholars but more
important of the pen scratches by which
he conveyed his immortal inspiration to
the world this is a manuscript of one of
his string quartets
what music that cannot be heard is dead
the library with the help of a few
generous patrons gives life to its music
collections by presenting eminent
artists in regular series of concerts
typical of such occasions is this Sunday
afternoon performance of the Budapest
string quartet playing on a library's
collection of Stradivarius instruments
when Beethoven was born the United
States that today honors the cultures of
all nations in these halls of learning
had not been founded this fact gives a
special significance to the manuscript
that Americans prized above all others
in the library's collection the
Declaration of Independence enshrine in
a wall where it can be seen by all who
enter this sanctuary of freedom is the
earliest statement of American purpose
these people know much of it by heart we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable rights that among
them are life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness Thomas Jefferson who wrote
those phrases 169 years ago and who
pledged his life to give them meaning
was one of the founders of the Library
of Congress
he knew that democracy must eventually
be based on the foundation of an
enlightened people
that is why placing facts within reach
of the citizen becomes the business of a
government and that is why the first
Tuesday in every month is so important
to our young friend and the farmers in
the hills of Virginia
you